hi I'm Sam from dogfish Head brewery and
you are watching the first we feast here
Inquisition serious
Dogfish Head is proud to be a member of
the Brewers Association which is the
tree group that represents the vast
majority of America's 3,000 and growing
small breweries and we felt it was very
important to have a definition so there
was some line in the sand
differentiating true small indie craft
breweries frankly from the largest
breweries beers that might taste good
and be good good quality and consistent
but they market them as if they came
from a little local craft brewery I'm
thinking of brands like Blue Moon shock
top that come from the world's two
largest brewing conglomerates we felt
that consumers deserve to know who makes
their beer and we're hopeful and we see
in sales trends that people do want to
support small indie breweries that kind
of keep the money that the income from
their breweries in their community
support all the jobs that are right
there in their community and people are
going sort of back in time to the era
when you go to the banker the butcher
the brewer as part of your daily life
and you can get what you want
locally so I'm glad there's a definition
that we've changed the definition
collectively as an association from 2
million to 6 million barrels which
sounds huge in the context of the
average of the 3,000 American breweries
is probably less than 5,000 barrels and
annual production you contrast that to 2
million that sounds like a huge number
until you think of it in terms of market
share and the largest to India American
owned breweries enabling in Sam Adams
Boston beer each respectively dominate
1% market and the largest of the bloomin
conglomerates aniseh Busch InBev that
now owns Corona that one company alone
is over 55 percent market share with all
those brands and then the second Miller
Coors SABMiller of course has somewhere
around 30 so collectively the 3,000
small indie breweries share 10% market
share and we really believe that a
rising tide floats all ships and if we
help each other grow instead of
infighting we'll all benefit
the concept of American Bureau was
frequently like an international joke
you know there was we find your American
Bear is a little like making love in a
canoe
it's [ __ ] close to water 40 years ago
that was sort of the stereotype of
American beer is this really like
generic thing and you know I had talked
to all the American craft brewers who
had the guts to brew bold flavorful
interest in creative beers and bring
this diversity vibrancy back to the
American beer world because we did have
it free prohibition every city made
really interesting beers that were
colorful and reflective of the
population of that city like
Philadelphia down the road had lots of
German so awesome lager breweries here
yesterday in what became New York lots
of Dutch lots of English so awesome
sales and we lost all that
post-prohibition a few giant breweries
brewing generic or homogenous I'll call
it beer went national and kind of
dampened a lot of that vibrancy well now
we have it coming back and now you see
Italian breweries by Washington State
hops and you know English breweries
coming over and getting our yeast from
America and it's wonderful to see you
interplay and certainly most of the
international cap doors I know give
props to the American craft brewing
scene for bringing that diversity and
craft and created this back in the
international scene but I would punish
any American brew in the throat it
didn't say what the Belgians have been
doing for centuries is significant in
terms of creativity for what we're doing
here in America so it would be absurd
for American Brewers today to say oh we
invented putting creative ingredients
I'm very thankful that sites like great
beer and good advocates exist but I also
think there's a little bit of a
phenomena of both at restaurants too
busy nobody eats there anymore meaning
people in that site if a brewery hits to
a certain scale is recognized outside of
that little community they write them
off as oh now that other people know
about them they're not as good anymore
so this continual search for this super
rare white whale that exists in those
communities
it goes to an absurd place if you play
it out but I'm so glad it exists even
with that negative component I wish it
existed when dogfish opened in 95 to get
the word out everybody's palette is
different and the reason there are so
many beers is you know taste is
subjective so to have as many styles as
possible whether they fit within
stylistic guidelines is great you know
our brewery makes over 30 styles of beer
we hope half a dozen would piss people
off and they hate them and coz then we
hope that they'll find an equal amount
in our portfolio that they love we love
to see breweries stop coloring outside
of the stylistic guidelines and it's
what we've been about since we've all